pienso que en parte eso es un acto
extremadamente provocador y peligroso
por parte de presidente Kim Jong porque
eso se sale por completo de las normas
de comportamiento internacional cierto
de respetar soberanía Y esto es una
amenaza para tanto el tema de la
Aviación y la navegación del Pacífico
Así que lo que estamos viendo
básicamente que es que Corea del Norte
está perfeccionando su Arsenal balístico
internacional para convertirlo como un
arma netamente nuclear uno giba nuclear
y decirle a Estados Unidos prácticamente
que ellos también pueden lanzar un misil
que haya tenido esas fallas en este en
estas dos últimos lanzamientos implica
que cada vez lo están perfeccionando
Bueno usted ha adelantado ya que Corea
del Norte podría estar lanzando misiles
balísticos intercontinentales es decir
un misil que puede alcanzar otro
continente Aparentemente ayer saltaron
las alarmas en Japón por el lanzamiento
de uno de este tipo de misiles que
podría haber fallado en pleno vuelo está
lejos a un Corea del Norte de contar con
esta tecnología
Yo pienso que no como todos sabemos
Corea del Norte cuenta con el apoyo
cierto Aliado estratégicos de Rusia y
china Así que ellos en la medida han
intentado o han hecho esa esa
participación o esa tecnificación de
estos misiles Sí ya han dado más alcance
ya logran 4.800 kilómetros más por el
Pacífico y realmente esto es un llamado
reitero a que este domicilio que dice es
que Estados Unidos y se ven amenazados
por Estados Unidos ellos podrían lanzar
un misil hasta Washington o hasta las
costas de Estados Unidos
hablado usted del apoyo de Rusia y de
China hacia Corea del Norte teniendo en
cuenta que Rusia está en medio de una
guerra en Ucrania y que china también
tiene problemas en el ámbito
internacional con Estados Unidos podría
encontrarse ahora Corea del Norte un
poco más aislada en el ámbito
internacional
no lo pienso porque Estados Unidos
precisamente está apoyando Ucrania y en
estos momentos online porque le interesa
tener a sus aliados estratégicos como
chile Corea del Norte Así que en ningún
momento veo que ellos estén alejados por
el contrario donde haya un ataque
Precisamente en conjunto de Corea del
Sur y Estados Unidos yo creo que Rusia
también participaría y obviamente daría
las amenazas respectivas a Estados
Unidos por involucrarse en temas de
soberanía que no le corresponderían